- Hello, everyone.
And I welcome you all to our session
on Making Agents Remember
Using Amazon Bedrock AgentCore Memory.
So before we begin our session,
I'm Mani Khanuja,
I'm principal generative AI
specialist solution architect
at AWS.
Very excited to be here
with you today morning.
And before we begin,
can I have a quick show of hands
for people who are aware
of the memory concept
in the agentic AI world?
Okay. Awesome.
So we have many folks who are aware of
and we also have few of the folks
who will be hearing about the agent memory
for the first time and
what role does it play.
And today I also have with me Jay,
who's our product manager,
and Imran, who's from Experian,
you know, sharing the stage with us.
He's the senior VP, head of
engineering from Experian.
And he'll be sharing the journey
and how Experian has been
using AgentCore Memory
for building their applications.
So very excited to be here.
And I hope we all have had your coffee
so that you're all awake.
Is that true?
Okay, awesome. Let's get started then.
So the main thing about the memory
when it comes to agentic AI
applications is providing
the right context to the
agent at the right time.
And that's what we see
the agent applications
without memory lack.
And by the end of this presentation,
I promise that you will understand
and also see a good demo
on how it can make the difference
when you're building the
agentic AI applications.
So let's talk about the context first,
what goes into the context of an agent
and what really this agent is.
So when I think about agent,
it's literally a model that has
access to some of the tools.
It can take actions on your behalf
based on the tools that you provide.
Now those tools could be some data APIs,
real-time APIs that you want
the agent to give access to,
or it can be access to
your knowledge store
where you have your organization data,
or it can be instructions
and system prompt is super important
because system prompt is what
makes the agent understand
what it's supposed to do, right?
So there's so many things
that goes into the context
of an agent.
And that's where we have seen
that memory is often overlooked.
But imagine you are in a party,
you have been talking to few people.
And suddenly after the
conversation is over
and you're like, "Oh, what's your name?"
Right? So we don't want our
agents to be in that situation,
especially when they're
interacting with your users.
You also want to give
a good user experience
or customer experience
in addition to providing
relevant and accurate responses.
And that's where memory plays a big role.
And it literally is, you
know, bridging this gap.
So let's take an example.
So obviously like, for this presentation,
we had to build our presentation, right,
the slide deck.
And then when we were discussing,
we were like, "Okay, why
not take this example
and share how you can build slide decks."
So we build a slide deck agent
that can do a lot of things.
So I started with a very
basic agent with no memory.
It was good. It was able to do the work.
If I provide a big prompt,
I give all the instructions,
it's able to generate the deck.
I have to give some tools,
such as, I love Python.
So I provided some tools like
Python-pptx and all of those.
And it did a good job.
No doubt about that.
But then I noticed, every
time I have to mention,
"Oh, for technical
presentations, use this style."
I'm in AI, and responsible
AI is close to my heart.
So in all of my presentations,
I want some angle
about how people use this
AI responsibly, right?
So those are my preferences,
which I wanted the agent to remember,
but with this basic agent,
I always have to provide
these instructions
over and over again.
So how do I overcome that?
That's where I created
another agent with memory.
Now, this agent could understand
my preferences over time.
When I was building a lot of slide decks,
it learned my preferences.
And then after a while, I just say,
"Oh, for tech presentation,
this is a tech presentation
on this topic,"
and it'll just do the job.
Not just that,
because I know when we
are talking about it,
we make it sound very simple.
So that's where we will show
you this demo up and running.
So stay tuned. It'll be at the end.
So you have to stay for that.
And also I want to make sure
that you understand the fact
that how memory bridges this gap
when you are interacting with the agent.
So when the user is
interacting with the agent,
there is conversation,
there is a lot of context
that agents need to remember.
So we have to make sure
that that context we are
providing to the agent
so that they give response
in an accurate, reliable way,
relevant response, and also
give good customer experience.
You don't just want your
agents to remember stuff.
You also want them to be smart.
And they can only be smart
if they're able to retain that knowledge.
If they have the full
context of your application
or the job that you are asking
the agent to accomplish,
you want the user preferences,
or maybe the facts,
or maybe the summary of
the previous sessions
to be remembered and
retained by this agent,
or maybe the agent should be
able to call those things.
So those are the things
which are very critical.
For example, you had a long
conversation with the agent,
and then you come back
and you want to do is basically resume
from that conversation.
That's a very common use case.
But imagine if you are storing
the entire conversation
history, it'll go so big, right?
So you might want to summarize it
and maybe when your user comes back,
the agent can say,
"You know what, last
time when we interacted,
you talked about these topics.
Do you want to continue with these topics,
or you want to start a new one?"
So those are the things
that you want your agent
to remember, right?
It would be so cool.
So that's where you want your
agent not just to remember,
but be smart about it, be
able to recall those things.
And that's where we are going to show you
how would you do that.
Now, let's talk about this demo sneak peek
that I talked about, right?
So the first thing,
when you're building
an agentic application,
you need the interface.
Your UI should be
attractive, should be nice,
but at the same time you
need some kind of a framework
to build your agent.
So in our application,
I'm going to show you two agents.
One, the agent without memory.
Second, the agent with memory.
And you will see the difference.
We are going to give the same prompt
to both of these agents.
And I'm using Strands Framework
to build these agents.
Then of course the main layer,
we are talking about memory,
we want agents to remember, right?
So then for this demo,
I have the Memory Hooks.
So why Memory Hooks and
what are these hooks, right?
So within these frameworks,
when we are using to build
agents, there are two ways.
One, you can use memory as a tool
or you can use memory as a hook.
So why we use memory as a
hook if we want to make sure
that agent calls the
memory at a specific time
in their lifecycle.
For example, on every message added,
I want my agent to add it
to the short-term memory.
And then there is a long-term memory,
which agent needs to retain
the key specific facts, right?
Maybe I can use that as a tool
because whenever the agent needs it,
it can retrieve from the
long-term memory, right?
So that's how you need the memory hooks
and sometimes memory as a tool,
depending upon your application.
Memory hooks is a more
deterministic way of agent
making sure that every message added goes
to the short-term memory.
Then when you are using these frameworks,
there is a session manager
that you might need,
and this will become more clear
when we'll, you know, go
through our presentation.
Then there is a configuration,
like what gets extracted
from the short-term memory
and goes into the long-term memory.
So you should have
control over that, right?
So in my demo, I'm using the memory config
where you can literally
override the prompts,
figure out what gets extracted,
and we are using user
preferences for this demo.
And all of this will become clear
when we'll do a deeper dive
on how, you know, AgentCore
Memory will help you out.
And the last but not the least,
I want to mention the
services that we are using.
So I'm using Amazon Bedrock,
Anthropic Claude Sonnet 4.5 model.
I'm using AgentCore Memory.
And of course security is super important.
So with IAM permissions
and integration with
memory makes sure of that.
It makes sure that I'm
only giving the permissions
that the agent needs to do its job.
Nothing more than that.
This helps me in reducing my blast radius.
So one of the key principles of security,
the principle of least privilege.
So that's what this does.
So now you have looked
and you have got some idea
about what this demo
is going to look like.
But now imagine,
you have to build all of this on your own,
the whole memory system.
I'm not even talking about
building agent and deploying it,
just the memory system.
Imagine, you have to do
all of this on your own.
What would you need?
So short-term conversations,
or the short-term memory,
should have everything as is,
like some raw messages, some storage.
And you should be able to give, let's say,
last K turns to your agent.
So that will maintain
your conversation history.
So there's the short-term memory, right?
Short-term memory is
literally like raw messages.
I should be able to retain.
I should be able to call.
So you need some kind of like a database
or a key value system which
can store these messages.
Now, long-term memory is that
the agent should remember.
For example, if we are
talking about user preferences
across multiple sessions.
So I need a different type of
a data store over there. Why?
Because based on the query,
the agent should be able
to semantically retrieve the information.
When I say semantically,
I mean based on the
meaning of the cushion,
it should be able to extract
the right information.
So I mean maybe a vector
store for that, right?
Now, these two storage systems,
I have to make sure that I'm managing.
There is a memory refresh all the time.
My data is refreshed. I
have automatic pipeline.
Whenever there is a
duplicate user preference,
it's consolidating, it's
updating, it's not really,
oh, you know, adding new
preferences without consolidation,
because imagine if I tell
you that I'm a vegetarian,
and I'm a non-vegetarian,
what will you serve me when
I'm, you know, with you?
Nothing, because you are confused.
But because I was a vegetarian earlier
and now I'm a non-vegetarian,
it makes sense for me to
order non-vegetarian food
or the agent to give me,
you know, recommendations
of the non-vegetarian
food, for example, right?
But if I give both those things,
the agent will get confused,
"Oh, what do I need to do now?" Right?
So the consolidation logic
becomes very important.
So you have to do that on your own.
And you have to do all of
this in a very secure way.
And not just that,
imagine something happens
while your user is interacting
with the application
and you need to troubleshoot,
or you need to debug,
you need to build and
integrate observability
into your system.
So all of this becomes
really, really lot of work
and heavy lifting.
So that's where we have
Amazon Bedrock AgentCore
to help you out so that you can focus
on doing what you do best,
is building applications
for your customers.
And we take away all that
heavy lifting from you
and you should be able to
quickly integrate memory
into your agentic applications.
Now to go deeper into
this, now I'll invite Jay,
who is the product manager
for AgentCore Memory,
and the best person to talk about it.
(audience applauding)
- Thanks, Mani.
I think in that case with the meal,
I'd probably go vegetarian
just to be safe.
All right, so we built AgentCore
Memory, as Mani mentioned,
to ensure that your agents
have the right context
at the right time.
It's a fully managed
service that addresses
many of the traditional challenges
associated with agentic memory.
Let's look at how it works.
So we're gonna do another
thought exercise here.
I want you to think about a conversation
that you've had in the last week or so.
You probably remember that
conversation pretty well.
Maybe even word for word.
Now, why don't you think
about a conversation
you had about a year ago?
If you went to re:Invent last year,
think about a conversation at re:Invent,
or a presentation at re:Invent.
If not, maybe last
Thanksgiving or last Christmas.
Now, for that conversation,
for that interaction,
you probably don't remember it super well.
Your brain probably remembers
the most important details
and generally what happened.
And you might have used that information
to inform future conversations
or future interactions.
That's how your brain works.
And that's how we designed
the AgentCore Memory as well.
It all starts with your memory,
memory resource, excuse me.
That's this blue and slightly pink box
surrounding your short-term memory
and long-term memory here.
Within the memory resource,
which you set up in your AWS account,
we have short-term memory.
That's your raw interaction history,
that word for word that
you remember more recently.
And that persists for from
seven days to up to a year
based on your configuration settings.
And then we also have long-term memory.
And your long-term memory are
that important information,
those key insights that
persist throughout.
And your agent can retrieve
both short-term memory
and long-term memory in order
to complete the job at hand.
So let's start by looking at
how short-term memory works.
In short-term memory,
your agent interactions are captured
and sent to the memory
resource in the form of events.
Events contain an actor
ID, so who this is,
or maybe who it is combined
with what the agent is,
and a session ID
which is generally your
specific interaction.
And the actor ID and the
session ID can be used
in conjunction with the events
with that raw information
for easy context tracking.
Events can contain your
conversation history.
They can contain metadata.
And they can also contain blob payloads.
So images or audio, things like that.
This is most useful for
hydrating your agent
with the recent conversation history
and the recent interaction history.
This is sort of the
baseline at this point.
And this is that example Mani gave
of having the conversation
and then someone comes back
and says, "Who are you?"
You know, no one wants their
agent to be a goldfish,
is what we say.
And short-term memory is
really good with that.
It has a few other uses as well.
And for that I'd like
to talk about a topic
that is near and dear to me,
unsuccessful so far.
And that topic is convincing my family
to get a golden retriever puppy.
So I've been unsuccessful so far.
And I'm thinking about a new approach.
And that new approach is using
the PowerPoint builder agent
to create a PowerPoint
convincing my family to get the puppy.
So I'm going to tell it to
include a bunch of cute pictures.
I'm going to tell it to include
some of the pros of getting a puppy,
getting a dog in general,
which include that it
teaches responsibility,
that statistically people
who have dogs are shown to be happier.
And I'm also gonna ask the agent
to do a bit of a financial analysis
to address some of my family's concerns
that maybe costs are an issue.
So I've put in a lot of effort here,
gone back and forth with the agent.
And the most annoying
thing that can happen,
the screen goes blank.
Let's say I quit by mistake.
Now it can be really painful to get back
to that exact point.
Can be a lot of effort.
With AgentCore Memory,
conversation history can be stored,
and also interaction state can be stored.
And what that means is
that you can go back
to the exact spot where you are,
and hopefully I'll keep you posted,
next year at re:Invent,
we'll have a puppy.
AgentCore Memory supports a
few other advanced features
for event organization
with short-term memory,
one of which is branching.
Branching is useful for going back
and editing messages or editing events.
And it's also useful for
concurrent event streams.
So what that means is,
let's say I put in some
effort for this presentation
and I wanted to get the agent to go off
and build me one presentation
on getting a golden retriever puppy,
one presentation on getting
a Siberian Husky puppy,
and, you know, maybe one presentation
on getting a German Shepherd puppy,
though I doubt that last one.
AgentCore can do that with branching
and maintain logical separation.
So that's short-term memory.
And now we're gonna look
at long-term memory.
With long-term memory,
your raw interactions short-term memory
are automatically transformed
into structured and persistent insights.
Unlike short-term memory
where the interactions
are, full interactions,
your full conversation
history is captured;
with long-term memory,
we only pull key insights
that you're going to need over time.
It's a multi-step process to
capture these interactions
and write them to long-term memory.
And as you may have guessed,
we're using large
language models for this.
You may also be wondering
how we know what information
to pull into long-term memory.
And the answer to that is by
choosing a memory strategy.
We have three built-in strategies:
summary, user preferences, and semantic.
And it's very simple to add those.
You go into the AWS console,
or add them via API,
or programmatically you
pick the strategy you want,
you add it,
and information
automatically starts flowing
from short-term memory
into long-term memory.
So really easy, we really like that.
The strategies themselves
are pretty self-explanatory.
Summary condenses down your interaction,
condenses down your
conversation, and saves that.
User preferences captures
the user's preferences.
So for me, for that
interaction we talked about,
it might be the user
prefers golden retrievers
and Siberian Huskies to German Shepherds.
And then semantic captures
facts about the interaction.
So that one might be user has a family
and family wants a dog, hopefully.
You may also want a little more control
over what you send into long-term memory.
And that's what those bottom
two strategies are for.
So with the override strategy,
you can choose which large
language models to use
and what prompts to use
to send information into long-term memory.
Self-managed gives you complete control
over the extraction process.
So what we do with that
is we deliver the events
to an S3 Bucket and notify you of those.
And you can pick up those events,
bring them through any sort
of processing you want,
and write them to long-term
memory as memory records
via our dedicated APIs.
All of these strategies can be,
memory records created
from these strategies
can be retrieved semantically,
so based on a query search.
And memory and strategies
can be combined as well.
And if you think about it,
it makes a lot of sense to wanna
summarize your interactions
and also capture facts about it.
So if you're creating an agent,
summary and semantic
might be the way to start.
And then as you want
more control over time,
think about looking at
override or self-managed.
So let's put all of this together.
We're gonna start on the left side here.
As we remember, interactions,
conversations are captured
and sent to the agent as
short-term memory, as events.
Depending on the strategies
you've configured,
those events are sent
into long-term memory
as memory records.
Both short-term memory
and long-term memory,
both events and memory records
can be retrieved by the agent
to complete whatever task it
is that the agent's completing.
You may have also noticed,
we now have Agent 2 and Agent 3 up here.
Multiple agents can write to
and read from a single memory resource.
So that's an option you can make.
And we can support multi-agent use cases.
Or we can support just one.
Yeah, so that's AgentCore Memory.
It's a fully-managed service
with built-in observability
and enterprise-grade security features.
And now I'm going to pass things
over to my friend Imran at Experian,
to talk a bit about his
organization's experience
with agentic memory.
(audience applauding)
Need that?
- Thanks, Jay.
I am Imran Shah.
I'm here today from Experian
to talk about what you have
heard from Mani and Jay
in terms of putting this into perspective
with the likes of an organization
and enterprise scale.
So I'm here to talk about Experian journey
of how we have moved
from a short-term memory
to a unified memory architecture,
and especially using AgentCore Memory
to simplify our direction within Experian.
As all of you can experience today,
the whole AI across enterprise
is a rapid evolution.
On a daily basis, it is changing.
And that is how Experian was
thinking before AgentCore
in terms of short-term
memory as Mani said.
We talk about something, we
introduced with our name,
and I forget who you were.
That's short-term memory.
So we have actually pivoted our roadmap
with this whole AgentCore
long-term memory architecture.
And we have adopted that in
the pilot mode within Experian
and I'm gonna you through
that journey today.
A little bit about Experian.
As you know, the credit
bureau all across the globe,
we have credit bureaus.
We are a innovative global
data and technology business.
And our main aim is
to work towards the
financial health for all.
We have around 1.5 billion plus
consumers across the globe.
And we serve both small, medium, large,
201 million plus businesses
across the globe,
across the geography.
From our richness perspective,
we serve 25,000 employees
across 32 countries.
And from a domains-wise, you
can name it as you can see,
cable to credit, not only credit,
but also data solutions,
automotive, healthcare.
And we are delivering this
whole with the 99.9% accuracy
of data across multiple domains.
Now let's talk about
Experian AgentCore journey.
As you heard from Mani and Jay,
we started our journey with a short-term,
very product-specific
memory implementations.
And very quickly we realized
that's not the way to go,
and we changed our unified approach
to more conversational context
and moving towards long term.
What AgentCore has also brought us is
rethinking our roadmaps
in terms of how Amazon
Bedrock AgentCore Memory,
we are actually moving
to more time to value simpler journeys
and pivoting our roadmap towards that.
And we'll talk in subsequent slides
about how we are doing
that in perspective.
So as you can see in this diagram,
our current memory implementation is
across products in two different ways.
One is managed memory
where you have assistance which
are using tools like OpenAI,
providing thread-level memory.
In the right hand side,
we also have custom
memory implementations,
which are some of the agents leveraging
OSS open service frameworks,
again providing thread-level memory.
In the contrast, as you can see,
we have a managed and we
have a custom, both coexist,
which creates a lot of user frustration
and confusions across teams.
So from a short-term memory perspective,
as you can see, it works,
but it doesn't scale into
the enterprise world.
A very small company
with even 500 employees
or 200 customers,
even in that regard, short-term
memory has some limitations.
Starting with the first one,
which is more around continuity
and persisting the long
conversation histories.
The second one is more
around performance and cost,
which is very important
to all organization
at any scale levels.
We also have cross product recall issues,
which leads to a lot of user frustration
where no memory recall happens
across the threads or products.
And last but not the least is
the compliance and regulatory
where it is difficult
to meet your regulatory
or compliance needs where
you have to go back two years
and represent any retention requirements.
It's very difficult to achieve that
with the short-term memory.
If we now move on to more
context orchestration
and how unified memory has
changed our whole implementation
and the roadmap with this,
as you can see, there are
two planes of context here.
We have a authoritative context,
which is more around
knowledge bases, APIs,
you have databases,
the things which are kind of
your knowledge ecosystems.
And you have a conversational context
which has short-term memory,
it has long-term memory,
and it also has the agent state.
When you combine these
two planes of context
into a more context workflow,
it becomes very impactful
for an organization which can scale
from an enterprise perspective.
Your LLM reporting can
be much more efficient
and your user personas can
give you the user context
which is required by a user.
Before, pre-AgentCore,
our planned architecture for
unified memory look like this,
like any other build scenario,
a classic build scenario
where you have a conversational manager
which stores and retrieves
all your conversations.
You also have a memory manager
which stores and retrieves memory records
powered by a typical memory
store or a vector DB store.
And your ETL pipeline is
kicking off periodically
in order to feed this.
So this model had a lot of, I would say,
significant operational complexity
due to managing multiple
custom components.
So this was pre-AgentCore.
Now let's talk about what was,
after we have implemented AgentCore,
a long-term memory
assumptions into our roadmap
and into our architecture.
As you can see,
it is lot more simplified
both in direction
and also in terms of the architecture.
With this, you have a fully
managed conversational store,
you have a fully managed
conversational APIs,
and you have zero ATL overhead
for your extraction of your memory.
What it brings to the table
for a enterprise-wide scale
is faster time to value,
improved operational efficiency,
and a lot of increased functionality.
In this scenario, our engineers
focus on building agents
and not worry about the infrastructure.
So this is how we have
simplified our direction,
and we are still in the
process of improving
towards a better scale and a
better roadmap for Experian.
Our code design principles
which are underpinning
all of this architecture you have seen,
the current state and the two state,
is leveraging these four pillars,
evaluation and test frameworks,
which actually continuously evaluate
your memory extraction processes.
We also focused on cross-agent
memory interoperability
so that we can enable
agents to share memory
across different agents
because then they can
orchestrate with each other
and give you a very informed opinion
with the context in mind.
We also have shorter targeted
context windows with this,
which keep it very purposeful and concise.
And namespace-based isolation,
which every enterprise would need
in terms of achieving
multi-tenants architecture
where you can serve multiple tenants
with the same master shared
kind of architecture.
So these are some of our
core design principles
which are not only met
with this whole design,
but also we keep this on a daily basis.
Now, this is where a design
for privacy, transparency,
and control comes in.
The whole memory governance service,
which we have designed with this,
it's a unified first way to
manage long-term AI memory.
What it allows is a user
can selectively delete
their own memories if they don't need it
and an administrator would be able to,
will have an ability to
purge it on a periodic basis
when it is required.
So it gives the control in hands of a user
and also in the hands of administration
if they need to take some
action in terms purging.
The whole approach actually enhances
great user experience, trust,
and more importantly it ensures compliance
for guidelines like GDPR or CCPA.
And these are very important,
because at the heart of Experian,
we believe in security, compliance,
and user experience all together.
So I think AgentCore Memory
architecture is bringing
all that to life for us.
It's solving multiple problems
and also giving us a way to
scale at the enterprise AI-wide.
With that I will also thank our partners
who have helped us doing
this implementation
from Tiger Analytics and AWS team.
And at this time,
I'm more than happy to
hand it over to Mani,
to take us through a very impactful demo.
With that, thank you so much.
(audience applauding)
- Okay, I'm back. Hard to get rid of.
Okay, no worries.
So now that you have understood
about AgentCore Memory
that Jay went deep into,
the constructs, the
components, how it works,
and especially I would like to thank Imran
on sharing how Experian has
been using it in their products
and how it was able to
simplify their implementation
and also scale.
It is so important to make sure
that your agents and your
applications can scale.
And when we are building AgentCore Memory,
we are taking that into mind
because that's what our customers
like yourself have been asking us, right?
So with that, I know
it's time for the demo,
which I promised to you
right in the beginning.
So are you all ready for the demo?
- Yes.
- Okay.
So this is the demo that I
built using AgentCore Memory.
So, as promised, there are two agents,
the basic agent which has no memory,
then the memory with the
agent and a comparison thing.
And as you can see,
I have some slides that I've
already built out using this.
So my agent now should
remember my preferences.
But let's see the basic agent first.
You can see there is like
it doesn't have any memory.
I can build some prompts, provide it.
It's a full running application.
And I have to provide the prompts,
I have to mention that
I like the blue theme.
Or if I don't mention anything,
it will just use the default.
But when I go to the memory-enabled agent,
then as you can see, it
can remember my styling.
Like for technical presentations,
I like the purple theme,
I like the technical font.
So because I have already
built out presentations
using this agent,
it's able to capture it
in the long-term memory
and also some real world use cases
that it should include in
all of my presentations.
And also it shows my obsession with AI.
So it's capturing that, you know,
the user likes to build
the AI presentations.
So it literally shows that I'm into it.
And then you can literally
create a smart presentation.
And now I don't have to
specify my preferences
over and over again.
But who am I to say that?
Let's see it in action.
So with this agent comparison thing,
I'm going to give the exact same prompt
to both of these agents at the same time.
And as you can see,
I'm not going to provide my preferences.
Even this prefer and
clean, let's remove that.
Let's just make it simple.
What type of presentation
I want, the key components.
So now this is behind the
scenes what's happening.
So you can see my prompt,
behind the scenes,
it calling the basic agent first.
It gave the whole prompt.
And after this, now you will see
that it is also calling the memory agent.
Let's take a closer look,
the topic and stuff,
so that it can search the long-term memory
behind the scene
and find the relevant preferences
related to the content.
But I also need preferences
related to the styling.
So then it's again making a
call for my styling preferences
and finding and searching and retrieving
the right memory which might be relevant
to build this presentation.
And then it is applying those things,
as you can see in the backend,
to build my presentation.
So it's all done.
Now let's take a look into
and get back to our UI.
So there are two comparisons.
And it's also giving a good understanding
and a summary what these
two agents have done
based on the styling,
based on the preferences.
So with the basic one,
it is using blue because
that's the default theme
that I have provided.
But for the styling that it has applied
to the memory agent is the purple theme.
Yes, I'm obsessed with the purple color.
(clears throat)
So now let's take a look
again at those preferences
because I want you to remember those
because when you see the actual slides,
you're able to correlate
this purple theme,
tech font, AI ethics.
I'm obsessed with AI. It shows everything.
So my agent knows me, right?
That's the main idea behind it.
So now let's take a look into the deck.
Now you can see there is
AI ethics tech added to it.
Let's take a look at the basic one.
Blue team, it's a default one
because I never provided what I want.
No styling preferences.
It is still doing a really good job
as I explained you earlier.
It is giving the slide,
the format, and everything.
So now let's take a look
at the memory agent.
Look my style, purple color, tech font.
This is basically the font
that you see while you do the
coding in one of the IDEs.
So I like that.
So now you can see those
concepts into the presentation.
So it's not just about my
style and the preferences.
But even if you look
closely at the content,
you will realize that it has
incorporated those things,
the content that I prefer in my deck.
Obviously this is 25 slides,
I couldn't go through all of them,
but I've showing you some of those ideas.
And if you are interested,
this demo is actually in
our GitHub repository.
If you search AgentCore Samples GitHub,
under Memory, you will
see this full demo code.
And you can try and play it yourself.
Okay, so now that we have seen this demo,
it is using AgentCore Memory.
Simply, I was able to
integrate, based on the APIs,
my existing agent.
I started with the first basic agent.
And then I integrated
this with the memory.
I literally called some of the APIs.
It took me few minutes to do that.
But then there are a lot
of other use cases as well.
The example that I gave
you is literally related
to the content creation example.
So you have this on the slide, right?
But there are way more use
cases than these six of them
that I'm showing you on the slide deck
because obviously there is not much space
and not much time to talk
about all the use cases
in this hour.
So let's take an example of
some of the other use cases
that might be relevant to you.
So a quick show of hands,
have you used coding
assistant to build your code
like WhiteCoding?
Okay, I see a lot of them
on the left side, center,
and the right.
So you are aware. Okay.
Have you noticed this?
When you are using the coding assistant
and you provide all the instructions,
it generates the code.
Then you run the code, there
might be some issues, right?
And then you give some
additional instructions.
And there is one instruction specifically
that at least I give when I
use the WhiteCoding thing,
is make changes using
minimal lines of code.
Do not create any new files
if they are not needed.
Because agents usually when
you ask them to fix anything,
they will create a bunch of test files.
So that's like every time
you have to type those instructions
if your coding assistant
doesn't have a memory.
So have you noticed that
one? Or is it just me?
Okay, I do see some nodding heads.
Absolutely. So that's an indication
to integrate your coding
assistance with AgentCore Memory.
It'll make your job easier.
You don't have to type these instructions
over and over again.
And whenever you are making
an edit, you're just saying,
"Oh, edit this file?"
How cool will that be?
So that's one use case
on how you can build a really
smart coding assistant,
which can literally remember
your preferences, your style.
Maybe you love coding in Python.
So it should not generate code in Java
or it should not continuously ask you
which language, for example, right?
So personal to you,
understanding your experience,
giving you a better experience.
And this is exactly what
you want for your customers.
So another example,
let's talk about a customer support agent.
Now, with the customer support agent,
you would call the customer
support for specific issue.
For example, talking about a refund
or maybe something else that
you don't like the product
and you want a replacement, for example.
Or you just want to complain
that it took so long
for the product to arrive.
So those are some of the
queries on the customer support
for a e-commerce thing, right?
We all do online shopping.
So I just thought let's use that.
Now, what you want is you
want this customer support
to remember the past issues.
Why? Because you want to
understand your users better.
Is this customer having the
same issue over and over again?
So what's going on?
Maybe it's time that you
might want to update something
or maybe for the agent
who's on the other side
can quickly look and
say, "Oh, you know what,
this is how we fix the issue in the past,
let's do the same thing again."
So those information becomes,
that type of information becomes critical
to providing good
experience to your customers
who are on one side
and to your agent who's
actually interacting
with the customer and
providing a better experience.
So memory becomes important
because that shows how much
you care about your customers
because you are remembering
their preferences.
You are not just giving them
the accurate and reliable help,
but also remembering them.
That's the thing that you want
to give to your customers.
So also I want to make sure that next,
whenever you are building
an agentic application,
think about not just
the accuracy, relevancy,
those are very important,
absolute must things to have.
But also think about
your customer experience.
Also think about how you can
minimize these number of calls
that the agent has to do,
because that will save
you the cost also, right?
So providing the right context
to the agent at the right time.
You have AgentCore Memory
as one of the components
that will help you
without you having to do
too much heavy lifting
because we are taking care
of that on your behalf.
So with that, there is a next step
that I really want you to do.
What we have presented today
is actually the beginning.
It's not the end of the presentation,
it's literally the beginning.
There is more to come and
more to be seen and heard
at this re:Invent.
So I invite you to join
keynote by Dr. Swami
who will be talking about the new features
that we'll be launching
across our agent code line
of products or services.
And also I want to invite you
to build one of these use cases,
connect with us, either on LinkedIn,
or shoot us an email or reach
out to your account teams,
and they can connect you with us.
And I'm so excited to hear your stories
and understand what you are building next.
So with that, thank you so much
for your time today early morning.
And I know it's difficult
to get up, but you are here.
So thank you. Thank you.
And thank you for that.
(audience applauding)